what's up with the one with the old lady
and her daughter
in joshua tree on mushrooms yeah that
was interesting
yeah yeah i when we discovered this
stuff a few years
a few years after we discovered
psychedelics i started thinking i was
like
uh this would be a fun thing to try to
work into our filmmaking like i don't
know how we could do it but it'd be fun
so again like i did with the bowler i
just started telling people like
here's what my next project is it's
gonna be these people it's going to be
people tripping
if you know anyone let me know and i
asked this girl
ryan warsley in seattle she's a
filmmaker and i was like ask
ask if seattle's a perfect area to do
this ask people around here
like six months later she hits me up
she's like nobody would trip on camera i
asked a bunch of people
but my mom's never tried psychedelics
she wants to try them and she said she'd
be down for you to film us and i was
like
yeah when are we doing it so a month
later we're in joshua tree
gave them an eighth of mushrooms each
and uh it was
[ __ ] beautiful it was uh you know the
mom's 72 years old
yeah never she didn't really even have a
reference point for psychedelics
and she's like i just literally have no
idea what this is going to be so
we spent the night before with them just
cooking dinner chilling out like
explaining what this could be
preparing them for it and showed up the
next day and just shot them tripping for
like six seven hours and uh yeah that
film is called joshua tree and i feel
like it's a prototype for stuff we want
to
for for future projects we want to make
we wanted to see if it was even possible
to do this and depict the psychedelic
experience in a way that
could get you kind of in their mindset i
think we pulled it off and then
we made another one of um our friend
ayla
taking uh two and a half tabs of acid in
woodstock that one's called sweet
nothing
and that yeah that was the last film we
made uh it's kind of my proudest film
because sweet nothing was the most
recent one yeah
when did you do that one uh 2019 2018
okay yeah
the cove had slowed us down a little bit
but um yeah she
[ __ ] did she was she was the chick
who when we were making our movie cam
girls we met all these
psychedelic cam girls in um in seattle
and we had only tried mushrooms but they
were way into acid and they turned us
onto acid and dmt
and a couple years later ayla calls us
up and she was just like i think it's
time that you filmed me take acid
i was like [ __ ] yeah cool let's do this
so we just rented a house in woodstock
and
you know pretty easy we all took acid i
was
i was tripping off camera and we just
hung out for a day and
i wanted to i want them to be i want
those films to be really visceral i do
not want to feel like the audience is
having its hand held through this
this experience there's no expert that
comes in and says here's what's going on
and it's just like
purely just with her and that was a
really fun one right that sounds amazing
yeah
yeah and well i mean it started with uh
with us tripping with it well with us
discovering this stuff and be like oh my
god everyone needs to know about
psychedelics like they don't
yeah i feel like it's just such a
foreign scary dark thing for a lot of
people
you know if you don't know anyone who's
done it and you don't know you don't
talk to somebody like you yeah a lot of
people i mean it's it's not something
that you're going to come by very often
even our parents
did not trust any of this stuff they
didn't like when we were just always
very honest about with them about what
we were doing it
honestly took like five years of them
seeing
the results of us being more conscious
it's for them to be like
fine what is it what are you guys doing
i'll do it i'll [ __ ] try it
you know both my parents did acid when
they were when they were young like
teenagers
and hadn't touched in 50 years and since
then my the
in the past couple years i've taken
mushroom with my dad
a number of times giving him [ __ ]
awesome molly a million times
really acid i've given him a candy flip
once we went to a grateful dead concert
and it helps him he struggles with
depression he struggles with suicidal
ideation
when someone is when their ego is taken
over
and all the negative stories have
bundled up that's what depression is
and all it is is misdirected creative
potential
and it's just you're putting all your
creative potential into reinforcing this
negative story
and the mushrooms or the acid or
whatever just comes in just dissolve
that story temporarily
giving your body your cells your muscles
your nervous system a break from that
tension
and i think that's why people feel such
long-term benefits from it i've seen it
with my dad
when you make like a like a like some
sort of series
that makes it easier
for people to be comfortable with the
idea of trying mushrooms
yeah that what that's that's what i mean
the joshua tree kind of
like okay i'm watching this lady take
mushrooms now it's kind of i feel less
scared now yeah
well that's like am i gonna be more
scared than her right
right she was she puking by the way into
that she thought she was going
okay she held it down man
like for a 72 year old lady to take an
eighth of mushrooms like
she just had a good [ __ ] time she
just loved it yeah but that's kind of
she was kind of like convulsing though
yeah i know i was like this isn't a good
look
she's like i was like yeah that's the
come up that's that's kind of what it
feels like
oh [ __ ] but honestly that that
what you're saying right now is our next
project where
we want to make a film called the family
trip
where we we're interweaving three
families tripping together
and and make make a 70 80 minute thing
that is palatable so you could show your
mom and be like
here check this out and she might want
to do mushrooms and because we've
tripped with our parents we've dosed our
parents we've we've
done all that stuff at this point and uh
you've got your parents take mushrooms
yeah
and acid and they're trump supporters no
okay
none of our parents are are like that
okay i thought you said that they were
no no uh our aunts and uncles just
family just right every single person in
our extended families besides our
parents
are okay our trump supporters they're
just like typical
yeah yeah yeah so the family trip
is uh hopefully a film we'll be making
soon
so do you operate the camera when you do
this stuff no you always get a camera
operator and sound guy
yeah that's usually uh that's the bare
minimum we've we have
operated cameras on some of our things
like when it's completely necessary but
i like the i like the subjects to be
distracted with me okay
you know because i can engage them in a
way where they're they forget about all
that [ __ ]
so that that's like my main focus is
like
you you get what you give you don't want
them to be focused on the camera
no i don't even want them to florida man
was a little different because we only
brought one lens so we knew the camera's
gonna be
like a character in it because we're
gonna have to get so close to get
close-ups and
like it's it's almost gonna become a
thing where you see them reacting it's
great
but um yeah usually we hire sound camera
cast does everything i i just
ask questions and find subjects and
that's the more expensive way of doing
it
yeah is it i always do i always do the
camera operating and the talking myself
whenever i do that kind of so
i do a lot of that kind of stuff so it's
like i just like yeah i take the camera
with the microphone mounted on it and i
just oh wow so you did like deck hands
and stuff i was watching those those are
great
yeah just like that wow and the sound
came out good that's what i always get
worried about a lot of times it's shitty
but um
i [ __ ] with it in post and try to make
it usable if
it sounds great well we watch sounds
great i'm always wondering about
people's sound approach because i'm like
that is the one thing it's like
[ __ ] man this looks this is it's
intimidating the thing
the there was like a moment there was
like a a film this kid did
that was on went on youtube year like
probably a little over 10 years ago that
like got me into
wanting to like start creating stuff and
putting it out myself what was that it
was uh i
i want to say that isaac worked on it
but maybe i'm totally wrong
but um this dude named some samoan
ketchup ours or something like that he
made this music video called love deluxe
where it's basically it was the first
like pov video i ever saw
and it's basically uh he's like
following this girl through all these
different towns and stuff like they're
on a beach and he's like following her
through all these different
personalities and like you just have to
watch it it's hard to explain but cool i
wonder if isaac shot that it was a
really cool music video and it was shot
on like
the first 5d that shot video but i know
there was a guy that had to like walk
around
with a camera strapped to a helmet yeah
and i want to say that he was part of it
i could be wrong
oh interesting i'll have to like isaac
shot like 300 music videos oh yeah yeah
i think he was a little upset after
florida man because so many people are
trying to get him to do documentary and
he's like i'm more of a sci-fi guy
you know so he's like taking off his
website not even a doc guy and like we
pulled him into that world and he had a
lot of fun with and we've had a lot of
fun together and we're going to work
together again but uh
he's totally like what the [ __ ] i'm
getting hit up about all this stuff in
in that world now isn't that so he's
probably just like full
he's like full on getting hired by like
tv networks and stuff doing like
he's like union guy now yeah he he does
he shoots a lot of stuff for uh
american horror story i think something
like that there's all kinds of shows
that he's
it's such a different world when you're
when you're like working for like the
established
networks doing that kind of stuff versus
doing stuff like that you do or like
stuff
that's why he craves he craves us after
after enough time away he's like all
right
what are we doing now tp's are always
excited because they
it's kind of hard to believe but we're
like we're gonna shoot for like four
hours
you know and then we're gonna call it a
day just hang out you know because it's
more about
it's the vibe it's about it's the vibe
so we have to keep our vibe
good so we can put a container around it
so that when we're going out
we get what we want and it's like that's
that's where sean's kind of different
because he doesn't as a documentary
filmmaker doesn't overshoot he kind of
if anything maybe undershoots to make it
really easy for kathy
to go in the edit and also just he gets
the pieces he wants and puts out
well i i just i i know what i know what
we want going into it and once i feel
like we got it i'm like
i'm not going to torture my subjects or
my crew because of my insecurity about
not getting something whatever we got is
perfect
and we're gonna make it work yeah i
didn't even know that's not how other
people work until
you know we work with people like isaac
and they start telling us about how
other documentarians shoot and i'm like
holy [ __ ] they're like oh they want you
to roll 18 hours a day
whatever you see just [ __ ] get a shot
of it brutal i can't i can't work like
that's too tedious
it's too tedious i would already bailed
on this medium yeah you need to do it
your way you need to do it you like i
mean you clearly did that with florida
man i mean
you like read that was like uh it
redefined anything like there was
nothing like that before that i know of
i appreciate it especially on the
internet
yeah yeah yeah it's just like the same
way kind of like podcasting is a new
thing
over the last 10 years or whatever it's
kind of taken off now but yeah
that is kind of like its own little
thing that no one ever
people didn't take that and run with it
yeah yeah it's
uh well it's some it's like like i don't
know it's just it's just raw footage
with no music or b-roll yeah
yeah i like that i like to tell people
um you know they're like wow you didn't
use any music or whatever and i'm like
watch it again there's a dope soundtrack
in there but it's just happening in such
a natural way you don't notice it it's
happening
when a bar door swings open and you hear
fleetwood mac
and we're with a cab driver and he's
playing david bowie and we're with these
[ __ ]
weirdos from cocoa beach and and you
hear [ __ ] jethro tull in the
background like
there's like little things that we me
and my editor were really getting off on
the edit like
like whoa there's like a secret
soundtrack to this thing without being
obvious about it it's there
like just like little things kind of
bring that to life so you mean it was
already there or you guys added it
no we didn't add it okay we didn't add
anything um but
like what we what we discovered in the
edit were like well there's a soundtrack
to this movie
and if it's so what i would think it
would be because i lived down here and
it
seems like music got frozen in time in
like 1998 down here
and it's like you know like like god
smack like i wouldn't hear that anywhere
else you come down here you throw it on
the radio and it's like oh
they still like puddle of mud and god's
smacking like
what year is this yeah so yeah all that
like just like little stuff like that it
was such a pleasure to edit that movie
it was just like
four days you know the way we edited
that one it's like it's like um
i like to think of it like i'm putting
together a mixtape when it's something
like that because it's all these
disparate stories it's all
nothing has anything to do with each
other so i'm just like this guy's a song
and then this guy's a song if i was
making a mixtape for you
how would i want how would i want this
to feel you know the first thing does it
sets the stage and you want to take it
up a notch
and you want to ease it out a little bit
so you know i'm just kind of thinking of
it like
like kind of like music so we just start
putting it together and then we watch it
down and we say that guy belongs here
get this guy out of there
watch it down and like that movie i feel
like we watched it like five times and
we're like
that's the movie and we literally would
just upload it then you know just like
put this out on the internet yeah no
film festivals nothing like that
i